[Music]
hello we are here to present one open
network emulator this is the first cloud
scale emulator they allow the network
operators to proactively test their
changes onto the network before they
actually deployed and this is really
needed by the agile network because
right now we are going going towards
higher and higher reliability
requirement like Faunus or five noise if
you do the calculation you will find
that within one year you only have a few
minutes Tong Tong allowed and two we
just can't deploy and enable changes
without verifying them so open network
and emulator is designed to surface
horror so we allow the network readers
to satisfy what network devices they
want to emulate and we have a nice UI
like OneTouch UI they can click on one
button installer emulator and they can
logging into the emulated devices to
test their policies the young agile
deployment we also hope that the
research community and the Faculty's
universities can also use this for their
classes or verifying their research
ideas that's why we are open sourcing it
and we're releasing in January next year
so next we will showcase the open
network emulators UI you can see how
easy it can be used I will add my
colleague hasib to help show this demo
all right so I'm received and I'll be
going over the the front-end that we
build on top of one and the key idea
over here is that one in itself is a
pretty powerful tool which allows you to
emulate a large network but in order for
it to be used at a production scale in
Microsoft Azure we build a layer on top
of it that allows you end-users to come
in
not have to worry about the
technicalities of how things are fired
up just push in a list of devices they
want to work on and the front end takes
you leverage is one to fire up in fire
up in emulation that is actually higher
high fidelity in terms of the devices
that they've chosen and what else is
gonna get fired up so I'll go over an
example on the on the front end so when
one when a network engineer comes in to
verify a change on a show network what
they actually do is they come in they
log into the portal and they request a
deployment right and at that point they
can name the deployment whatever they
want to I'm gonna move over this side
for example in this scenario let's call
it test summit right I can assign any
password that I want I'm just gonna do a
random one
and for the devices here's what I want
to go over so the user does not have to
go and figure out what are the exact
speakers that they need in the
environment all they do is the picketed
device list from what whatever they want
to fire up
I sure has a bunch of devices right if
they plan to work on five devices they
can choose those five devices and just
submit a request now what happens on the
back end is this request get it gets
picked up and it's gonna get fired up in
Azure as a virtualized Network right
while we wait for this environment to
come up I have a similar environment up
and running so what I do want to
highlight over here is when the network
comes up you get your jump boxes which
are essentially what the end-users used
to interface with these network devices
so as an example the thing that I do
want to highlight over here is something
to visualize the network right now keep
in mind the user just requested five
devices right but you see a whole bunch
of more devices on this diagram and the
reason for that is that when a user
requests the device right so this as an
example is the device one on the back
end figures out what other devices it
needs to fire up to make sure that this
device acts the way the same way as it
would in production meaning that one
device that you picked over here it goes
and figures out what the boundary would
be and fires up a whole bunch of extra
BGP speakers to to make the right prefix
announcements to this device so when you
log into a device it actually shows the
right bgp connections coming up the
right interface is coming up and the
right prefix is announced to it so that
essentially is our one front end and
that's what we used to be using as well
to verify our changes thank you
[Music]
you